khi là món ăn bình dân ở Việt Nam,
nhưng chân tra người ăn đã gây sốt khi chêu đại trường bản ở châu Phi,
khiến ông không thể sức đủ?
Công giá quế ở người ăn và cộng sự xân thạc,
đã hai trong số các thành viện quên thuộc của những châu Phi
đã gần bỏ vui con linh vi lúc nhiều năm ứng ăn cố la.
Mới đây, chính tên của ăn có hơn năm chẳng tảm ứng lực theo dõi,
công giá bình dân thạc tới bản mayala,
nấu mất bữa cơm chuyên thống kiểu Việt Nam để chêu đại chà sử,
chứ bản và một người dân địa phương.
Bữa cơm này không có xe thảo hay vị và chỉ tòa những món ăn tục sạc
cơm nhàng nhau ở Việt Nam, như đậu sán,
cà sán và xo bùng lực, các món đều được chế biến đưa dân sản
cho cùng với nước mạm mặt đặc trưng.
Môi cơm bệnh hành người Việt và thường tức bữa cơm chuyên thống,
nghe dân châu Phi không giống đổi được thạm tích thủ.
Họ cũng bài tỏng sự xúc đậu trước bỏ con khi đặc ấm như một gia đình
và linh tục tốt lên ngon quá,
bữa ăn ngon nhất đặc nhất từ trước thời này mà chà được tưởng tức,
lên đưa tín ăn như thế này, thế chà cũng muốn học còn và xúc đối như người Việt Nam,
chết sửa bài tỏng.
Hơn người cuộc đời đây là lên đậu chung cuộc đời bác,
được ăn món ngon đến thế,
đoàn sức ngon và con được bài biện đẹp mắt,
bắt sẽ về kể lại với bà con trong bản vì bữa cơm với hôm nay,
bữa đây đủ chất mạm bắt từ được ăn,
trong bản nói thêm.